esse negócio essas viagens eu não sei
falar um negócio do inglês que tem que
saber né o inglês porque eu sei que
disseram que a gente tem que aprender
mas tem que saber às vezes eu fico
indignado vou falar a verdade que a
pessoa fala aprender inglês é muito
importante aí eu digo por quê sen não
porque mais oportunidades de trabalho
por quê Porque você sabe inglês e por
que que ninguém quer saber o nosso
porque você já sabe o nosso Aí fica
melhor PR mais fácil entendeu fala
inglês aí eu não preciso estudar e
quando você vai pro meu país eu ainda
sou melhor que você porque aí falou
Olimpíadas fala não não pode por qu
porque está preparado por qu pessoas não
sabem falar inglês eu fico meu Deus aí a
desgraça sai lá da desgraça vem pra cá e
eu tenho que saber a língua da desgraça
porque senão ô desgraça aí eu fico puto
ó Aí tu faz o qu eu faço humor né
comédia eu escrevo crio projetos eu sou
ator eu faço filme bô Então vem PR cá
fazer um negócio aqui de Claro você sabe
falar inglês e o inglês eu não sei por
que você não sabe inglês ainda que o meu
meu país fala outra língua mas tem que
saber de suma importância